juste ça va au sol comme de l'
eau dans laquelle
vous mettez le tube et vous le scellez
avec votre pied comme ça
donc c'est un moyen rapide de planter un arbre
salut mon nom est grodd j'ai 21 ans et
j'ai planté
10 000 arbres en Irlande, nous sommes dans la
réserve naturelle de Dunstane, qui est l'un de
nos sites de plantation d'arbres et ce qui est
vraiment spécial ici, c'est que c'est l'un
des seuls endroits en Irlande que nous ayons
laissés pour se régénérer
et revenir à la nature
[  Musique]
donc mon projet s'appelle reforestation
nation
et l'idée derrière le projet est
de rendre euh la
restauration de la biodiversité et la lutte contre le
changement climatique accessible à tous
en mettant la nature avant le profit l'
objectif cette année est de planter 30 000
arbres
et dans les trois prochaines années  je
veux planter cent mille arbres
et finalement un million mais nous verrons
comment nous allons avec les cent
mille premiers et partir de là
j'ai de très grandes ambitions pour moi le
succès de mon projet n'est pas une question de profit
c'est à peu près combien  des arbres  sont dans le
sol
depuis que je suis jeune, j'ai grandi dans une ferme, donc
j'ai toujours été entouré par la nature
et j'ai vu des documentaires sur les animaux de
personnes comme david attenborough et
vous savez à la télévision m'a vraiment inspiré
pour y entrer et
mon ensemble  la vie j'ai été dans la nature tu
sais a commencé avec les dinosaures je suis passé
aux animaux et
finalement j'ai fini par étudier
la biologie de la faune à l'université
donc c'était en fait lors d'un verrouillage en
irlande l'année dernière pendant le coronavirus
j'étais assis à ne rien faire et
je mon père est venu  avoir une idée de peut-être
quelque chose à faire dans ma région et
j'étais comme oh cela semble être une bonne idée
parce que nous n'avons pas beaucoup d'arbres ici,
alors c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai commencé à trouver
des idées et à
essayer de créer un site Web  pour cela et en
pensant à ce que nous pouvons faire et cela a
fini par être non seulement quelque chose dans
ma région,
mais quelque chose que nous pourrions potentiellement
faire à travers l'
Irlande c'est le pin sylvestre donc c'est en
fait notre seul pin indigène
et ces  utilisé pour couvrir les montagnes en
Irlande, mais il y a quelques milliers d'années,
ils ont tous été abattus par les premiers agriculteurs
et l'une des raisons pour lesquelles ils pensent qu'ils
ne sont pas revenus est en fait parce que lorsque
vous coupez ces arbres
à la base, ils ne le font pas  recommencez si
vous allez dans les montagnes en Irlande,
vous y trouverez des insectes
et cette tourbière est en fait les
restes pourris des forêts de pins écossais
et vous trouverez toujours des
arbres comme des souches d'arbres comme des
pins sylvestres vieux de cinq mille ans
euh  toujours dans la tourbière et j'ai en
fait des
morceaux d'écorce d'il y a cinq mille six
mille sept mille ans à la
maison
que j'ai récupérés dans ces
tourbières dans les montagnes, donc
et de ces quelques arbres originaux que nous
avons pu vous obtenir
connais une population et maintenant nous sommes en train
de reboiser l'Irlande avec ces
espèces autrefois
éteintes  nge et vous savez que
la crise de la biodiversité
et le changement climatique sont les deux plus grandes
menaces pour notre monde,
vous savez si vous avez une bonne biodiversité,
cela aide la plante à résister au changement climatique
et le changement climatique lui-même peut endommager la
biodiversité, ils sont donc très liés l'un à
l'autre
et  planter des arbres est un moyen de combattre les
deux que vous connaissez si vous créez un
écosystème plus naturel,
cela aide le réel, cela aide tout
à faire mieux à partir d'ici
et aide en fait à rivaliser
avec les espèces envahissantes que vous connaissez,
comme lorsqu'un écosystème
est  endommagés parce qu'ils ont la chance d'
entrer là
-bas et de faire des dégâts, l'abattage des arbres est
certainement l'une des choses les plus importantes
que les humains aient faites à la planète
parce que nous avons enlevé la moitié des
forêts du monde,
donc malheureusement nous avons affaibli notre
planète  en supprimant nos arbres,
ce qui signifie que notre planète est moins en
mesure de lutter contre le changement climatique
et de s'adapter et les arbres sont formidables
car ils
fournissent de la nourriture pour  tant de types
d'animaux différents comme nous plantons la gamme la plus
diversifiée de toutes les initiatives en
Irlande
et ils fournissent beaucoup d'abris pour les
animaux, donc ils sont un moyen d'
accomplir beaucoup en faisant simplement une
chose simple comme planter un arbre
alors oui le  la meilleure façon dont les gens peuvent aider est
simplement d'aider à financer nos efforts de plantation,
car
il n'est pas trop difficile de planter les arbres
une fois que nous les avons disponibles une fois que nous avons
les sites,
donc plus il y a de gens derrière nous,
plus nous pouvons planter d'arbres